puis le soleil trompeur réalisé par le
russe mikhal corps qui tient à nous dire
que les hommes ne sont pas tous blancs
ne sont pas tout noir voici le coup de
coeur l'émotion forte que l'on attendait
c'est nadia et son père nikita mikhalkov
qui nous la forte avec leurs amours
leurs lumières
une journée tranquille en 1936 une
famille harmonieuse une datcha au bord
d'une rivière et tout bascule parce que
le soleil de staline est trompeur
ce film nikita l'a fait pour nadia
sans du tout simple claire et évidente
mais qui peut garantir qu'un moment un
autre ne sera pas affronter un destin
proche de celui de l'héroïne du film se
termine en un instant et l'histoire de
la russie
c'est cela soviétique qui était dans le
dialogue parce que ce modèle n'existe
plus et réalité n'existe pas ce que
c'est que nikita et le colonel cocteau
ou en couleur à nuire et encensé puis
menacé finalement exécutée pour l'avenir
plus que pour le passé le passé il est
passé un film à la tchekhov qui montre
les charmes de l'existence en toutes
circonstances un film lyrique dédié à
une enfant pour que jamais elles ne
connaissent la menace du soleil trompeur